[Music]
okay i'm getting a challenge from a 1500
night owl
333 so i'm thinking
why not we can definitely accept
15 18 and let's roll the cameras e4 i i
guess this is a sub um which is
i guess fine with me since the rating
kind of fits
um okay so we're facing a
sicilian and once again
we go c3 we go for the alopen
which is what we've been doing this
entire time
okay d5 uh
okay so d5 is one of the two main lines
he takes d5 queen takes d5 d4 we've had
this
a thousand times on the speed run and
now black generally goes knight f6 or
knight c6 those are the two main moves
and as is often the case in the allopin
you have this tension between the c5
pawn and the c3 pawn and it's not
usually a good idea for black to take on
d4 prematurely
uh because it opens up the c3 square for
white's knight okay so knight c6 knight
f3
and and here i mean there's bishop g4
that you can bring the other knight out
to f6
and you can play e6 i mean there's a lot
of possible moves for black
uh but a lot of people really under 2000
are not intimately familiar
with uh with the theory here and if
black isn't uh familiar with the theory
he can get in some trouble because that
queen on d5
is both really a strength and a weakness
at the same time it's controlling a lot
of squares but it is incredibly
vulnerable
if we can get a bishop to c4
all right so in this position there are
a couple of possible moves
uh i think the move that i have
previously played in
the five minute speed run
is um
bishop or no the first speed run i mean
i meant to say is bishop b2 bishop b2 is
what most of you guys are probably
thinking of but it's actually not the
only move
uh and there is a move which is in my
opinion a lot more dangerous if black
doesn't know the theory does anybody
know what move i'm talking about now
this move essentially kills two birds
with one stone it
simultaneously guards against bishop
takes f3 which would ruin white's pawn
structure okay you guys are on the right
track knight a3 is the right idea the
only thing you want to do is do the same
thing but reinforce the knight on f3 and
the move is knight bd2 now you might be
looking at this and saying wait a second
now we don't have the connection anymore
between white's queen and the d4 pawn
can't black simply take on d4 and win a
pawn
well he can but
that's why we play knight bd2 we
sacrifice the pawn and we do so in order
to get very rapid development for our
pieces
and after c takes d4 think about what
white's going to do what is the idea of
knight bd2
is it just to recapture the pawn on d4
no it's not who can tell me what our
follow-up is going to be against
virtually all of black's moves with the
exception of bishop to xf3 it's going to
be bishop c4 we're going to start
developing with tempo
and then our queen from d1 can later
come out to b3 you should already be
thinking about that move because b7 is
vulnerable and f7 is also going to be
vulnerable does it matter that this
blocks in the bishop i mean it always
matters right it's a it's a drawback
it's a drawback
of of this line that it blocks in the
bishop but
we are prioritizing the development of
our other pieces now i i will be honest
i don't remember the theory of this line
too well
uh but we're going to reconstruct it
knight f6 okay that does not
fundamentally change
uh what we want to do so we we clearly
want to go bishop c4 and follow our plan
hit the hit the queen
okay bishop takes f3 i was expecting
that
and this leads to a very interesting
point in the game
where we have to decide on
our subsequent course of action
yeah well here's the thing guys
queen takes f3 allows a queen trade
and i'm not
a huge fan of a queen trade here because
that
essentially neutralizes our initiative i
would seriously consider first of all
taking with a pawn on f3 that's very
risky
but it might also pay off tremendously
because later on we can go queen b3 and
essentially hit both of these pawns at
the same time but there is a third move
which you guys are indicating which is
actually queen b3 simply ignoring the
bishop on f3 entirely now what's
important to establish there is that
black's queen cannot escape with check
if it could queen b3 would be out of the
question but this square is controlled
by the knight this square is controlled
by the pawn and e6 is obviously
controlled by the bishop
so
i really like the move queen b3 as far
as i remember this might be theory
i'm not sure maybe i'm messing it up
maybe i'm missing messing it up but then
i want my opponent to punish me so
we'll see we'll see how this goes and
again the point is that once the queen
moves i'm sure this is probably theory
i'm sure this has been analyzed we we
can then either you know take on f7 with
check
or we can potentially take on p7
but most likely we're going to take the
bishop on f3 recapture it with our
knight and we've done so while
preserving the queens on the board and
our initiative is going to be tremendous
because his king is nowhere near
castling short i mean he's going to have
to go one two three moves
uh before black escapes the center
assuming that black doesn't want a
castle long which just seems
very very dangerous given that black has
already exposed the queen side with the
move c5
yeah what about knight a5 some people
are asking well knight a5
there's a couple of things that we can
do there
uh the first is that we can
move the queen away with check
we can move the queen away with check
um and then black is gonna cover with
his queen and it leads to a very
complicated position so we'll cross that
bridge if we get there
we'll cross that bridge if we get there
if we don't win the queen
we do not win the queen after knight a5
because his queen is going to be is
going to be able to cover the check on
a4 or b5
so you might you might you guys might
say wait a second knight a5
queen a4 check
queen drops back to d7 and we say oh we
win the queen but this should be five
but remember pins can be blocked and
that bishop from f3 can return back to
c6
cover the pin and black is going to
emerge a piece up
and that's exactly what happens
okay
i think knight a5 is a very very strong
move i think it's actually the only move
to keep black in the game so let's try
to assess the options make sense of the
position this position is not quite as
complicated as it appears
if we give a check with the bishop
that's very bad
because then the king simply moves aside
to d8
the king simply moves aside to d8 and
remember our queen is going to be
hanging
and after bishop b5 king d8 queen takes
d5
the bishop from f3 can recapture on d5
and black is up a piece
if we take on d5 here
black is going to take on b3 and attack
our rook on a1 which means that in that
position we are gonna have to take that
knight on b3 but then black takes on g2
and the minor pieces are equal
but black is going to be up a pawn
that's also not
uh something that appeals to us and so
we kind of have to give a check with the
queen now where do we give it
um
between these two squares i prefer queen
b5 check because after queen a4 check
queen d7
it transpires that our queen is
undefended
but after we give this check
and black covers with his queen
we don't have to move the queen from b5
at all we can take on f3 with the knight
and the position you know the smoke
finally clears and i still think that
we're going to be a little bit better
on account of the fact
that um okay scratch all of that i was
not expecting queen c6 and i think this
is a mistake now it's very important
right to constantly be reassessing your
conclusions about the position
especially if you're faced with an
unexpected move how does the position
change as a result of this move as
opposed to queen d7 what did i mention
about queen d7 i mentioned that queen d7
leaves the c6 square open for the bishop
to come back and cover a potential pin
now here you might say well wait a
minute if our queen is gone from b5
bishop b5 is going to be a far more
serious threat
and so
we now have the option of playing
queen takes a5 now we have to check here
that black has no
additional
checks on the e file because they could
lead to checkmate but he doesn't
and that's exactly what we do we take
the knight with the threat of bishop b5
very very complicated position he goes
b6
which was expected now what should we do
what should we do
there's a very important follow-up move
here
yeah yeah of course queen a6
once again preserving
preserving the threat of bishop b5
now if
black plays this very astutely
the game is far
far from over but our opponent has to
keep his composure and find
the correct sequence of moves
let's see if
he's going to be able to do that
and you know as he's thinking try to put
yourself in black's shoes and ask
yourself how you make the most out of
the situation
not like that not queen b7 this is in my
opinion one of the biggest weaknesses
that people in this rating range tend to
experience 1500 1600 when faced with
something that looks like it may end the
game such as they're losing their queen
um
that panic creeps in and then you know
you know and then they don't end up
putting a lot of resistance in how do we
actually win the game here what's
white's simplest move
well we don't have to do anything with
our queen it's defended by the bishop we
can just take black's bishop on f3
emerging up a piece
that's it
the game is over
and only 12 moves but a lot happened in
those 12 moves
so i'll show you after the game please
be patient
i will talk about what black should have
done after the game
and there is a concept that i've
mentioned before which
would really help you to find
the best defensive option
yeah this is
this is resignable i mean this is just a
full extra piece
and to make matters worse black's king
is just still stuck in the center and
look at these light squares we're going
to return to b5 with check
on the next move yeah the bishop b5
check is a great move we can also play
bishop f4 and get this bishop out it
really doesn't matter at this point
let's go bishop b5 check just to make
sure the king stays in the center and
even though it's the end game we've got
plenty of pieces that we can use to
attack
uh and case in point in this position
once the king moves to d8 you should
automatically be considering what move
i'm not bulleting it out uh create i'm
you know i i'm playing a little bit
faster here but it really is the case
that i think the moves are a lot easier
to understand once you're up a piece and
making the quote-unquote correct move
matters a lot less
there's a big set of moves that are
possible 95 is correct
uh hitting the pawn on f7 i mean anytime
there's the king on d8 and the rook on
h8 you have to
uh you have to look for knight e5 and
knight g5 you just got to manually
consider that move okay
great game
so
aleppo and sicilian
knight c6 knight f3 bishop g4 knight bd2
uh knight f6
and let's get right to the meet bishop
c4
and bishop takes f3 now to be honest i i
under i underestimated bishop takes f3
uh and after queen b3 i do believe that
black had a move here
which i initially completely missed and
i think it would have given black maybe
even an advantage and so it is possible
that bishop c4 is a mistake i i might
have confused the theory
and now that i think about it it may be
the case that d takes e5 is the move i'm
not totally sure i'll have to look it up
um
okay so i am looking it up no it is the
move bishop c4 bishop takes f3 queen b3
oh no i guess i'm wrong so knight a5 is
the main move
but there is an alternative and by
talking about this alternative
uh you are going to help yourself
understand
where black could have improved um
instead of giving up a piece who can
tell me
an alternative to knight a5 and this is
a hard move to see very hard move to see
why is it hard to see
because you're taught from the moment
that you start playing chess the last
thing you want to do is give away your
queen blundering your queen is the worst
thing that you can do and so a lot of
players you know when they hit 13 1400
they develop this irrational fear
of anything that involves sacrificing
their queen and they they are blind to
options that involve giving away your
queen for a lot of material right you're
just not considering it because you're
thinking of it as giving away your queen
but if you consider it what about bishop
takes g2 well what happens there bishop
takes d5
now you don't just rush to take the rook
on h1 that's terrible
what does black do yeah this is still
theory i see seven games in the database
here
what is black play here
well the move is easy just yeah bishop
takes d5
and then the funny thing is
after queen takes b7
uh black has this move knight takes d4
black has this move knight takes d4
which leads to ridiculous complications
i see four games with queen a6
knight c2 check king e2 knight takes a
one both rooks are hanging
and you get a completely irrational
position where black is technically up
material black has two pieces and a rook
for the queen but black is completely
undeveloped on the king side
and the king is stuck in the center it
looks like white is achieving success in
this line uh and this is a perfect line
to analyze with an engine i mean people
watching on youtube if you're feeling
overwhelmed you could just analyze this
position with the computer for five ten
minutes and kind of get your get get
your bearings i also don't know what's
going on here i don't even know who's
better this is an impossible position
for humans to evaluate if i had to say i
would probably give my preference to
white just because black's king is so
weak black's knight on a1 is trapped and
i think it's practically speaking easier
to play this for white
in addition knight c2 is never a
possibility because of queen a4 check
forking the knight and the king so
so that's how the existing games have
gone in this line
i also don't understand why in this
position black can't consider rook b8
hitting hitting the queen
i mean it's the same idea the queen
moves and then you take the rook on h oh
i guess the reason is aha queen c7
bishop takes h1 and who can tell me a
crucial move here for white crucial move
and i've talked about this a lot even in
today's video on on puzzle solving
anytime there's a big distance between
two pieces that defend each other
consider moves that sever the connection
between them f3 very good and black
cannot defend everything the bishop is
trapped the knight on c6 is toast
i mean black is busted rook v6 t takes
c5 rook a6 and queen c8 would win the
rook
so
so i guess this line is good for white
but this existed
all right so 95 is the main move
queen b5 check
and here i think black made a serious
mistake yeah so the move is queen d7 and
once again
if white plays queen takes a5 here then
after bishop g2 bishop b5 black has this
additional resource of going bishop c6
and black is in great shape
right so the main line here is knight
takes f3 knight takes c4 queen takes e4
finally things
fizzle out a little bit you get this
kind of position where i think that
white is maybe a tiny bit better uh
because white is closer to castling but
black should be able to equalize e6
bishop b7 castles and you've got a
pretty symmetrical position with no
piece imbalances
um
oh so there's a question about bishop
takes f7 no
remember the knight is not on f3 yet so
bishop f7 doesn't actually give anything
because the knight can't get to e5 in
time
right
um
so queen c6 is a is a is a very big
mistake because now bishop b5 is a
threat but
in this position and b6 queen a6 i don't
really know who this favors but the same
resource existed for black both of these
times now now that we looked at the
previous line who can tell me how black
can make the most out of this situation
or at least try
i see now that this probably does not
help
but at least it gives black some chances
very good bishop takes g2
no guys if you move the queen you give
up the bishop right you can't just give
up a complete bishop for nothing
you have to instead give up the queen
for as much as you can get for it bishop
takes g2
bishop b5 bishop takes h1 and guess what
if white immediately takes on c6 which
most people would after bishop takes c6
yeah white can also take on c5 because
this is pinned white is
undoubtedly probably winning
uh but black has a lot of stuff for the
queen however as we already know white
is in no rush to take the queen
and
white can insert the move f3 i think
this is the reason why white is simply
winning
again
black now has to give up the queen for
the bishop
if you take on f3 then knight takes f3
and the queen is pinned
if you don't take on f3 if you take on
b5 for example then after queen takes b5
check king d8 i think the simplest way
of winning this bishop oh actually you
have the move queen back to f1 winning
the bishop on the spot so
i guess black's position is already
hopeless after queen c6
but this should have been tried now
after queen b7 this is the full piece up
and black loses on the spot
why not bishop b5 instead of queen
a6 well if you play bishop b5 here
then black is going to take the queen
and then once you take black's queen
black is able to take that bishop with
his bishop and at the end of the day
black is up a piece so there's no hurry
to play bishop the point is that you
have to move your queen away first
and black is unable to defend against
two threats at the same time that's all
it is this is threat number one and then
this is threat number two
and one of these is going to happen and
by playing queen d7 black ensures that
he doesn't have to defend against bishop
e5 because of bishop c6 these tactical
subtleties you know the more experienced
you are the better you become at
calculating the more you solve
the easier it's going to be to make
sense of these crazy positions so if
you're feeling overwhelmed and you're a
relative beginner don't be because with
experience you're going to
learn how to get your bearings in these
positions how to break it down into its
component tactical parts
okay
and that's about it
all right guys take care thank you so
much for hanging out great stream today
bye
[Music]
you